[Music]
good morning today's a beautiful day we
have um some special guests here
zoe
and maya being all cute why are you guys
so cute you know who else is super super
cute super super duper duper cute
my boys hi what are you guys doing
i was just recording some video footage
of him and he started farting on us and
then i was like
do i need to like
take you off because we don't want to
stain this this is our photo shoot oh
blanket it's always like do i need to
take you over there to
release some farts
you know we just finished taking
pictures of this little guy for his
three months and two weeks
update every single week we've been
taking photos yeah we've been using the
nice camera to uh
do photos and videos and to document his
growth right and with the lights you're
like modified you want the lights out
here
cutie
oh my god you're so cute
you're kicking my hand oh what's going
on
oh my mom's calling me oh
mama
hello luca
hi baby while they're up here hanging
out i'm gonna go downstairs
and make some breakfast
oh okay breakfast time man you know what
i've been having this blemish here on my
face
for like
weeks it's actually gotten a lot better
thank goodness
but this will not go away i don't know
why but anyway for breakfast i'm gonna
do a shake casey likes his almond toast
with
his coffee this is really cool coffee
that we get that's frozen what am i
gonna eat every day i'm like you know
what i gotta
i got i got so many options i've been
trying to consume more oatmeal
because
oatmeal is really good
for breast milk production is what i
hear you know what else is really good
for my breastfeeding body ritual
shout outs to rachel for sponsoring
today's video so i've been adding this
ritual essential protein to my shakes
every single morning it tastes so
delicious and i just absolutely love how
i'm able to now meet my body's increased
nutrient demands with rituals essential
protein because it contains all nine
essential amino acids inadequate amounts
which means it's a complete
protein it's also vegan soy free and
gluten free and it's formulated without
gmos i also love the fact that ritual
raises the bar with the quality because
they make sure to test every single lot
of protein to make sure that you're
getting exactly what's on the label they
also work with a third-party lab to help
ensure their products are compliant with
regulations and guidelines for heavy
metals microbes and major allergens so
that makes me feel at ease that i'm not
putting anything harmful into my body or
passing anything to luca i really love
how this protein powder is so delicious
it tastes like vanilla but you really
taste that creaminess
and it's not like other protein powders
where you can actually taste the fact
that it's a protein powder
rituals essential protein hits it out of
the park for me i really love it and
like i said i love adding it to my
milkshakes i every single morning i add
some fruit in there some oats some chia
seeds and definitely i gotta add my
protein powder
yeah that's good
so i recommend rituals essential protein
during and after pregnancy highly highly
recommend so you can check out
ritual.com tiffcase20 for 20 off your
first month or you can just use our code
tiffcase20 at checkout to get the
discount you can also check out the link
in the description to check out ritual
and they also have protein for adults 18
and older or 50 and older that is not
specific to postpartum or pregnancy so
if you're trying to add high quality
protein to your diet check them out
highly recommend them
[Music]
[Applause]
what happened
let me go check on my baby
and then he started crying we were both
laying down oh yeah he sounded like he
got hurt so i'm like oh my god what
happened oh hi mama can we scare him
hi
so what happened i think he was just
like i'm over this i don't want to lay
down no more maybe i don't know you got
tired of laying down or maybe he wanted
to show mama yeah his other side
all you ever show them is me smiling
i'm more i'm a complex human being
let me show you my other emotions
yeah he's like yeah i'm gonna meet you
yay
food's ready oh my sweetie
he's like rubbing his face
oh my baby
how was your nap
you took a nap while mommy was making
breakfast
so i made a shake with
oatmeal
chia seeds shredded coconut oh cutie
smiling i didn't see
he kept marks on his face too
from your shirt
uh rituals essential protein shake
vanilla shake with mango strawberries
spinach
that's it i was gonna put honey but the
protein powder already has like really
like the perfect amount of sweetness
along with all the fruits so i decided
not to taste it you've never tasted it
so let me know what you think
does it taste like protein powder
it just tastes good what's the texture
wait don't finish it that's for me
you okay i have been holding luca for so
long oh that's i think i need to be
taking that
shake right you're laughing
you're just getting heavier i know this
arm is
buff
right how do i look am i getting buffed
too oh yeah hey i think i'm shrinking
get healthy again i know honestly i'm
the opposite i'm blowing up so i need to
get healthy again too but honestly i
feel like we we need to like just get
back into it we need to get back into
our healthy routine yes take them out
more in the nature we've been wanting to
go hiking with them we should go hiking
today let's go back in the day you want
to go hiking baby after after breakfast
after for lunch technically pm breakfast
yeah
it's a saturday what do you want we
slept in it's okay we're fine it's a
saturday
hey cutie i made myself
a bagel with cream cheese great new
yorker review it's a
saturday making bagel cream cheese i'm
busting my chops here
all right let's do it i'm hungry
it's okay
you got it
you got it
baby
yeah
good job
this is big boy
big boy carrying now this is the first
time i have his legs sticking out
usually he gets carried with his legs in
like a newborn are you ready to go
hiking
it is time to go hiking it is a very hot
day in southern california we're going
to make sure
baby luca here is protected from the sun
and from the heat as much as possible
this is our first time doing anything
like outdoorsy and like minus the beach
minus the beach yeah well that's true
but that day wasn't it was windy but it
was very relaxing because it wasn't very
hot yeah this is toasty
sure
oh you're wearing your mavericks gear
i love his voice here we go the first
time i have him forward basically yeah
how is it it's like a roller coaster
you're on a ride you're on a safari ride
see what kind of wildlife we're gonna
see today it doesn't feel as supported
somehow as it would be if it was facing
towards you
i got bird poop hey you okay baby
[Applause]
hey you skipper
you look like a skipper now
[Music]
he doesn't look comfortable at all
[Music]
here we go this feels better
[Music]
i like how he's looking around
even though he's sleepy see all these
trees this is the world we live in luca
not inside the house like that's all you
know anyway it's bright out here
hey tuck down the swing
which is something isaac was looking
forward to
last time we came we were uh we had a
field day over here swinging here oh
well
[Music]
oh
our first obstacle
of the
hike you can do it
[Music]
just walk in the water though if uh if
you got a bale
[Music]
look i have to get my shoe at
to not fall
i could feel it soaking up my
sock just a tiny bit does it feel good
though because i feel like it that's
actually a good problem to have on a
super hot day soggy socks
no it's cool feet
he fell asleep
he's like oh i have a soundtrack of
nature here true if he goes to sleep to
waves
to either waves or white noise or
classical music or something
now he has a nature soundtrack so he
feels at home then yep i'm definitely
breaking a sweat this is definitely
physical activity oh yep yep yep this is
the first time i've
gone out and done something active and
like
since that luca's been born so it's
about four months of inactivity and i'm
definitely feeling it as i walk i can
feel my back jiggle
oh yeah
that's fun the excess mask that i have i
have games to provide
support for this one
i can feel it jiggling mm-hmm
it's like a
massage while you walk this is literally
the first and only time in my entire
life that i've really felt like
oh man like i gotta work out like i
gotta
i'm gonna lose some weight like
i've
put on more than i'm comfortable with
and i've never felt that in my 32 years
of life like really it's the first time
i felt that so
it's a different experience a different
sensation
but i'm still
trying to be very mindful of
appreciating my body
being thankful for what my body has been
able to do to provide life
so
i'm still very much loving my body but i
just want to give my body the healthiest
you know wait because i really feel like
out of breath i feel way way less energy
lethargic yeah lethargic
so that's how i know i'm like oh my
body's asking for attention
i need to give my body some attention
now
next step is to uh
run it drag it maybe
baby stuff baby steps okay
[Applause]
oh my gosh it's
nature it's not flying away i'd be oh
oh my gosh isaac that's amazing isaac
the butterfly whisperer
what the heck can i get you on camera
what
oh snap
is it hurt
it feels weird though yeah
is it tickle
a little bit it's going good
baby go
nice bye good luck on your journey
[Music]
my parents are finally in town to meet
luca
you guys ready to meet luca yeah
it
yeah
[Music]
you